bonjour je suis Olivier de montliveau le
fondateur et dirigeant de SOS accessoir
SOS accessoir c'est une entreprise que
j'ai créé il y a 15 ans maintenant et
qui est devenu en quelques années le
leader en France de l'autoréparation et
de la vente de pièces détachées pour
réparer ses appareils
électroménagés aujourd'hui nous
expédions des milli de commandes chaque
jour et nous aidons des dizaines de
milliers d'internautes avec nos compun
nos tutos nos vidéos à réparer à
entretenir leurs appareils
[Musique]
électroménagur c'est le fruit d'une
expérience que j'ai passé chez un
précédent employeur j'ai travaillé une
dizaine d'années chez chez Dary la
centrale d'achat accessoire de chez D et
c'est là-bas que j'ai identifié un
besoin suffis ent satisfait pour les
consommateurs de toutes enseignes
l'obtention de pièces détachées et
d'accessoires justement pour réparer ces
appareils électroménagés c'est très
compliqué à obtenir en magasin en SAV et
il y a 15 ans on oublie un peu mais
c'était les débuts de l'Internet
marchand et internet est un moyen
fantastique pour identifier et se faire
livrer dans des bonnes conditions de
fiabilité et de et de délai une pièce
détachée pour réparer un appareil éonger
au début quand j'ai commencé SOS
accessoir je n'avais qu'un salarié
aujourd'hui vous voyez on est à peu près
120 personnes chez SOS accessoires et
non pas chaque jour mais chaque semaine
ou en tout cas chaque mois de nouveaux
collaborateurs viennent rejoindre la
société alors là ici vous avez près de
500000 pièces détachées qui sont
stockées c'est le plus important stock
de France de pièces détachées
disponibles livra en 24 he depuis le
lancement de SOS accessoires nous avons
aidé à réparer plus de 3 millions
d'appareils électroménager et cette
année là en 2023 plus d'un million
d'appareils auront été réparés
entretenus grâce à SOS accessoir donc
c'est un million d'appareils qui
n'auront pas été rachetés mais qui
auront été réparés et au final qui
auront fait du bien à à tout le monde et
en premier lieu à la planète là vous
voyez l'Étap de colisage où sont les
opérateurs c'est par ce convoyeur
centrale quiarrive dans les différentes
caisses de préparation toutes les pièces
qui sont préparées pour toutes les
commandes qui sont tombées sur le site
internet dans les heures qui précèdent
ou la veille le coliseur prend une
caisse il scanne la pièce il prend un
des cartons que vous voyez là sur le
convoyeur sur trois étages de de
convoyeur qui aura préalablement été
formé automatiquement par une formeuse
de caisse que vous devinez là-bas le
préparateur prend la pièce prend un
carton met la pièce dans dans le carton
et met ensuite le carton sur le tapis
que vous voyez le carton poursuit son
chemin il va passer dans différentes
étapes de contrôle contrôle de scan code
barre contrôle pondéral on contrôle son
son poids qui par cohérence permet de de
s'assurer que c'est bien le ou les bons
contenus à l'intérieur photo euh et
ensuite il va passer dans la grosse
machine que vous avez là-bas qui est ce
qu'on appelle une fermeuse de caisse
vous voyez que le collier est ouvert euh
selon le gabarit du du carton il passe
dans l'une ou l'autre des fermeuses de
caisse le colis est automatiquement
fermé il poursuit son chemin il passe
ensuite à l'étiquetage transport et
ensuite ça monte jusqu'aux différentes
gare d'expédition chaque gare
correspondant à un transporteur et
ensuite les palettes les Rolls les les
bacs sont ensuite chargés dans les
différents camions transporteurs et et
collectés une ou plusieurs fois par jour
pour être livré le lendemain ou le
surlendemain chez le consommateur ou
dans le point relais choisi par le
consommateur là vous êtes au cœur de la
production de notre chaîne de télévision
sur Youtube donc là on est sur la
production de de contenu vidéo c'est ici
que sont tournés nos nos vidéos nos
tutos vidéos mais on fait la même chose
aussi en production écrit parce que les
deux sont très importants pour les
internautes et ce sont donc des équipe
interne de SOS accessoir des techniciens
électroménagers chevronnés qui vont
tourner devant une caméra avec des
cadreurs monteurs salariés de SOS
accessoires qui ensuite vont monter et
publier ces fameuses vidéos qui vont
aider les internautes à à diagnostiquer
et à réparer derrière donc là ici vous
êtes au cœur de l'atelier de réparation
SOS accessoires donc c'est un atelier
qu'on a lancé récemment et qui vient
clairement compléter notre offre
d'autoréparation maintenant ici à morpa
dans les evvelines nous faisons aussi de
la réparation pour proposer une solution
complémentaire alternative à nos
consommateurs alors voà principalement
en local he bien sûr puisque c'est
destiné aux consommateurs qui sont dans
les ivelines donc qui apportent leur
appareil et qui en quelques jours se
font réparer à de très bonnes conditions
leur appareil gros ménager ou petit
ménager vous l'avez compris à SS
accessoire est une société en forte
croissance en 15 ans chaque année nous
avons un niveau de croissance de 20 à 60
%. et pour alimenter cette croissance
pour passer ces différents paliers de de
croissance nous avons besoin de trois
choses principales des locaux on en est
à notre
5e site 4e déménagement évidemment les
hommes et les femmes qui composent les
équipes de SOS accessoires je vous ai
dit près de 120 collaborateurs de plein
de métiers différents et de plus en plus
de gros investissements mécanique it
informatique et d'automatisation demain
nous allons continuer à alimenter cette
croissance nous sommes devenus les
leaders en France et bien notre ambition
elle est très clairement de devenir un
leader en Europe d'autoréparation et de
vente de pièces et accessoires pour
réparer les appareils TR ménager